what's going on reject nation
greg and john here it's saturday the day
after our
wanda vision episode six reaction went
up so you know what that means
it's time to watch the master at work
eric vos from new rockstars
easter egg breakdown of episode six and
you know what
it's a thick one it's a long one he's
got
girth let's do this
are you making a piano welcome back to
new rockstars i'm eric boss and this is
a breakdown of one division episode six
a terrifying halloween with juandus hex
warping the whole world into a creepy
clown maze
the weeknd they're all musicians
damn clues that you might have missed it
just try to help us figure out
wanda the [ __ ] is going on let's get
started and again we gotta start with
the previously on segment it calls back
the real mcu pietro's death from age of
ultron
it's the first of many examples this
episode telling us that the evan peters
pietro
is not actually a recast as marvel has
done before but that this guy
is not pietro as the episode begins we
find ourselves in this early 2000s arrow
with graphics text punk music all
inspired by malcolm in the middle
newspaper has an ad for westview
appliances otherworldly deals and a
flying saucer hovering over head this
reflects the mentions of the lights
visible over west view in the newspaper
last week
and vision's very first line in this
series my wife for the flying saucers
i see all of this intended to be by
hayward an
appliance that he hoped to weaponize
against extraterrestrial threats
shifted away from manned missions and
focused on robotics
oh okay so that's what hayward's plan is
it says on the door
the world's not the same as you left it
space is now full of unexpected got it
okay
agnes has been added to the opening
credits wearing pants with
knotty now agnes of course has always
been playfully naughty but even more in
this episode we are seeing her even
greater
possibly villainous importance pietro
has also been added to the credits
as himself as if to say these others are
actors playing roles but this guy is a
celebrity guest star who's not playing
the part of pietro but just kind of
screwing around
as himself and oh damn it's a small but
significant
yeah i mean it stood out to me and when
we were doing our reaction to it i
noticed that it didn't say as himself i
didn't know what to really make of it
and
they were trying to throw us for some
loop on something but i feel like he's
onto something there
he's someone who's not under any
manipulation at all maybe he has
what it's so confusing and who is that
self you probably know where i'm going
but we'll get there the opening image of
the episode
ghost and i actually think the alive or
dead status of these west view residents
is now up for debate this halloween
billy wears a red cape and a blue
headband the wardrobe of wiccan in the
comics
you actually notice wanda vision pietro
they all match their comics counterparts
with their halloween costumes the kids
debate the true meaning of halloween
halloween's a
magical holiday all about family friends
getting to be someone else for a day
wrong halloween's about candy
and scaring people but mostly candy yeah
the thrill of getting to be someone else
for
a day kind of sounds like what this
mystery figure is doing as pietro he
looks false because this is essentially
a halloween costume version of the real
thing tommy's milk carton reads maple
hill organic milk the way nature
intended from pasture-raised cows
definitely a step up from bova milk in
episode two
being the bovine genetic creation of the
high evolutionary who nursed wanda in
pietro in the comics
these boys played dance dance revolution
on floor mats takes me back with my
favorite
track smile dk's butterfly yes
butterflies that wanna brought to life
oh crap i'm becoming that mean people
keep cleaning me hey
by the way if you want to extend this
nerdy conversation you can join us on
new rockstar's official discord do it
guys
patreon.com where is these tiger
slippers kind of like that toy tiger we
saw last
week no meaning of the time sensors hard
enough in slippers no wonder why they're
both miss
missing don't judge me this was my
primary cardio as a 12 year old
it really was my cardio too when i was
kid so good at that
i would compete with people i could go
to the arcade pietro snores on the couch
but as boys talk about them they use
this great
split focus technique it keeps pietro in
focus in the foreground while the boys
talk and focus in the background
what does it mean he is awake
eyes open actively listening but
continues to
deceptively snore you scared
he's your uncle yeah but then he messes
with him and tommy says
it's four o'clock in the afternoon
you're secretly afraid he's
vampire billy is a telepath sorcerer
like his mama so he's likely on to
something suspecting
true true
blood is thicker than water meaning
family bonds are the strongest
notice how pietro tries to replace
vision as a father figure
big guy is a conflict twins need a
father figure for the night
don't sweat it sis i got the old xy
chromosome
yeah and pietro did not like vision
punching him in the shoulder there
and then after vision absolutely kisses
wanda and then leaves
look at pietro's face there yeah these
daddies are
in competition oh [ __ ]
oh damn worse than the costumes mom made
is the year we got typhus
kobe is an awful place whoa flashback to
sokovia i love these soviet era
propaganda posters
rocket science and nuclear energy now
you could say maybe pietro could be
dressed like nick fury wanda like black
widow but
i don't know when these people were kids
neither fury or
how would they do that that's just for
us queen is not
really celebrated in eastern europe so
when wanda doesn't remember this it's
probably because
it never happened right now it's a joke
in the context of a sitcom but it is a
lie in the context of pietro juan
division argue and billy tells us
mom and dad have been not fighting
just like different and quick silver is
feeding into that
so it is proceed past the context of the
sitcom reality
because pietro is not under wanda's hex
wanda even senses this notice how she
locks the door after vision leaves
something maybe that she felt like she
should have done to keep pietro out last
episode
and it leads to this
don't do that yeah pietro is not a
calming presence here he is
bad news he has a mom tattoo on his arm
okay wait a minute i i didn't even pick
up on that like i knew that he might be
perceived as some type of threat to
wanda but it seems like he wants to get
vision out of the picture i didn't pick
up on any of these actual little details
that he was paying attention to but
evan peters is a very specific performer
and he can be subtle when the right time
calls for it so i could see these subtle
nuances
as an exceptional detail too he doesn't
want vision in the picture he just wants
it to be all about family and i love the
idea
that they're using sitcom jokes as a
disguise
because it really muddies the one yeah
like is this just a shtick or is this
yeah an actual character beat that's
gonna develop further oh
damn oh that's nuts i didn't i didn't
see that i
didn't see that's coming yeah yeah [ __ ]
but i believe that
i do that's too many little details he
has a mom tattoo on his arm some are
saying this could be for multiverse
madness some people actually thought it
said h-o-m but no it is mom
how do i know because evan peters has
this tattoo already so can things that
already existed before the script was
written by easter eggs
sure he's just playing peter there's a
drone that wanted them and this is
stamped with
stark industries this is a piece of 80s
weapon tech that the company used to
make before tony's change of heart
and like that stark toaster it is
exactly the kind of stark hardware that
would have triggered wanda's memory of
that stark bombshell
right right hayward says maximoff was
never going to negotiate with us we take
her out this whole nightmare ends
ah this is one of two mentions of the
word nightmare this episode it's a
pretty big leap from giving people
nightmares and shooting red wiggly woos
out here
the horrible demonic entity nightmare is
believed to be a possible villain of
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
and possibly the big bad behind all of
west view here oh it's impossible but
nightmare feeds off of people as they
sleep and as we saw from wanda's
exterior confrontation last episode
she's honestly during all this so i
think we can rule out nightmare just
because it's not as specific as those
grim reaper sightings or the devil stuff
hayward calls out monica's
insubordination constantly advocating on
behalf of super-powered individuals
yes i know your history with carol
danvers
and all you people who left still have
the luxury of optimism
yeah it's made to sound like it's
embarrassing to be associated with
captain marvel
as if there was some incident before the
blitz fricken larson explains why fury
was reluctant to summon captain marvel
every other time earth was under attack
perhaps captain marvel was looked at as
a pariah for prioritizing all these
other worlds instead of tara c-53
earth so then they go trick-or-treating
whoa unleash hell demon spawn
you know i keep bringing up my fisto but
this is why in the comics wanda's
children are actually revealed to be
pieces of the
souls and as i've been saying these past
seven days since finding that gray
corpse arm
in the mirror this ain't pietro this is
an
imposter wearing a pietro halloween
costume just with a bit of stunt casting
by marvel using a quick silver from a7
is that all
you really think it is might give us
mutants but this guy is a red herring a
pickled red herring and now this
mephisto has come to reclaim these
children born with wanda's magic sweet
but you were on twitter recently and you
said
you said that you're beginning to
believe that mephisto will actually
not show up in this series and that they
might just i don't think you said they
would just be nods
but you did say that you were starting
to think that he might not actually show
up in this series
so what is it eric vos i don't know i
feel like it's a quicksilver hybrid i
think it's a slam
slam bam both of them combined in some
way it happened thank you ma'am
we'll see can't just be stunned casting
come on i don't want to be just be that
to reclaim these children born with
wanda's magic so he can reap the
benefits
and he's doing it by wearing the
disguise of wanda's dead brother
wanda tests him here what was the name
of
that kid who was always trying to steal
your boots he hit the skin thing now you
could see this as an odd to the facial
scarring of victor von doom i don't know
maybe in the mcu you might hail from
sokovia you could have like experienced
that i hope they do have liberia though
i like these fake places
i love this in the background there's a
dude with a jason mask in the freddy's
shirt he's essentially
a [ __ ] freddy versus jason nice this
dude started the scene chatting with the
pirate in the jockey but for the rest of
the scene he just gotta aimlessly stand
by himself that would be me no friends
conversations though he is not as creepy
as this hook
nosed figure behind wanda later now i
thought this was a mannequin but look
down there that is a human
leg this looks like someone pretending
to be a mannequin just waiting to pop
out and scare people but they never
do which is even scarier
maybe a nod to the immortal himalayan
refuge founded by the vision of the
comics but maybe just used generally to
refer to james hilton's last horizon for
the mythical debates
that is interesting because i thought
we're not allowed to mention anything
now piss off china if tibet can be on
disney placement pistol can be on disney
plus my friends
oh okay there goes that tweet
conversation
well a lot of dead characters be coming
back i mean
kick ass so kick ass was a 2010
superhero movie in which
evan peters co-starred with aaron taylor
johnson and the way wanda says it it's
almost as if she remembers seeing the
movie pictures in the movie yeah
that's weird herb reports back each of
pietro's vandalizations before they
happen
all the cannon has disappeared
all the cannon has disappeared the
people get silly strings they're
frozen it's like they're already
glitching like the people on the other
side of town i'm telling you
pietro does not abide by the rules of
this hex he is a virus in the machine
we do you want something changed
as we saw in episode 3 herb seems to be
a bit more aware of what is going on in
west view let's keep an eye on it
meanwhile vision sees this woman stuck
on a loop setting up decoration behind
her her partner is also on a loop but
look
at their motion they have each been
looped in post-production i didn't even
notice the husband you can actually see
the dividing line in the frame she
noticed the husband before
no i knew he i saw it back there i
didn't see the repetition she died in a
shadow for the husband that goes across
that dividing line just to make it all
feel like it's part of one shot
even though there's no light on him that
would cast his kind of shadow so that
sad sad tear just makes all this feel so
unsettling letting us know that
something's inherently wrong here but
then
this terrifying commercial for your
magic yogurt now throughout these
episodes the commercials reflect a
different stage of wanda's trauma
and now this is wanda starving
emotionally alone in the void
a claymation depiction of what wanda was
trying to convey to pietro later in the
episode
wanda needs her magic to survive or else
she will rot into a corpse like her
loved ones
so like a vulnerable child she keeps
trying to feed on this magic
even when that magic is brought to her
by a sharp sharp-toothed
outside predator notice this little boy
has already mentioned
earlier turn pietro wait a minute
that commercial lineup does make sense
if quicksilver is really not quicksilver
as we discussed in our reaction that i i
thought it just meant more so
about like how vision is a corpse and
she's been using magic to keep vision
alive using the magic to keep him alive
i didn't really quite get the
justification the shark i just thought
it was a riff on the commercial
commercials that they were back then
yeah it definitely is that i kind of
took that as like predatory forces
feeding off of her magic not necessarily
pietro quicksilver whatever that is but
just yeah the forces yes
at work that are probably leeching off
of her or
poisoning her in some way aiding in this
i just
have a hard time believing quicksilver
is just purely some mephisto disguise i
have a hard time just believing that
yeah i notice this little boy has
already eaten a fish
earlier wanda threatened to turn pietro
into a pickled herring
they were given damn
between salvation and survival the
incredibles in the past
weird since one came out in 2004 the
other came out in 1998 they wouldn't be
in the movie theater at the same time
but this is kind of like the 2013 as a
great and powerful plane in the 70s era
of west view the incredible but the
incredibles could represent
family with superpowers family with
superpowers trap it wins coming back
together and then it's also
it's her trap that she's assembled to
get their parents to join the show
powerful plane in the 70s era of west
view the incredibles is about a
superhero family with powers taken
almost directly from the fantastic four
but here paralleling this
superhero family the maximoffs and the
parent trap is about
twins trying to trick their parents into
falling back why didn't my mind go there
why didn't i go better that makes so
much more sense
come to town unexpectedly create tension
with the brother-in-law stroke trouble
with the rugrats and ultimately give you
grief
he did just kind of declare his purpose
he wants to give
the gift of grief why because i think he
feeds on her pain
and then he calls out her accent what
happened to your accent what happened to
yours
yeah between civil war and infinity war
one dyskopian accent just kind of went
away
though it has started to come back this
will be your only warning
i think the lost accent and the sitcoms
are connected
wanda might have spent those two years
with vision on the run binging sitcoms
and she might have started
emulating the dialect of the character
she saw on screen and it was that time
that she is now trying to recreate
in this hex and then petrol this whole
show was just designed to explain
what happened to wanda this accent this
is all
one big visual representation of her
subconscious
all those complaints about what happened
to her accent guys we gotta plug this
we need a whole series just to explain
it i got
shot like a chump in the street for no
reason at all and next thing i know i
heard you calling me yeah he's really
kind of making fun of his own death and
age of ultron suggesting this evan
peters pietro is not the quicksilver
from the fox x-men movies who would not
know what erin taylor johnson pietro's
dying moments looked like but rather
this might be someone from this universe
or beyond this universe who saw that
death but is now okay with mocking that
heroic significance
who does that sound like to you so ellis
avenue is kind of the board
could be a nod to the mcu president
matthew ellis like maybe west view just
named the street after the president
matthew ellis was named after marvel
comics writer warren ellis ellis could
also be a nod to ellis island where
that's why the movie world leaders
gathered and were nearly turned
into mutants from the nearby liberty
island
her dad
remember visions vibranium was fused
with living cellular
tissue so as that tissue decays it could
cause the vibranium atoms in the cells
to radiate
out we see four circles in the bottom
corner maybe those are for the different
types of radiation
maybe they're infinity stone related i
doubt it not everything multi-colored is
infinity stone
is probably the late rpg and vision
decides to revert to his avengers form
and he uses the mind stone to do it
interesting it looks as though the
further away people get from wanda and
the hex the less she's able to puppet
them
though notice even after vision reverts
he does keep his wedding ring now vision
does not remember his avengers
history because he always i've always
caught this creation of wanda
he's free from the pain of everything
that happened before and that includes
him just seeing himself as a husband to
wanda
but that manifestation does invoke his
soul that he had before
that soul was good and truth seeking
that's why he ends up questioning this
reality and
is able to determine it's false now oh
no this agnes license plate reading okay
so the mind stones
real okay and like a text code for the
color red i don't know why people keep
saying that it's like a bluish black
shade i think it is significant because
it does
alternate zero one two abc and remember
vision of one this card episode one was
tagged
zero one zero two so it may reflect how
agnes by comparison is
literate in ways they aren't but of
course
the latest smoking gun that this is
probably agatha harkness there's a lot
going on here that's weird while other
glitching residents cannot even talk
their frozen catatonic
agnes can and then after vision zaps are
awake she still goes by the name
agnes she doesn't have an alternate
identity it seems like she
is more resistant to the hex maybe a
product of
it and that is why sword cannot identify
her notice how she clutches herself
that's because she's looking for her
brooch if she is a witch secretly
serving mephisto his soul could have
previously been kept in that brooch
that would be her husband ralph that she
won't shut up about the one who shares
an anniversary with her that's the same
date as the salem witch trials and that
maybe now that mephisto has taken human
form she just feels
lost without him and agnes says this am
i dead
no no you've just reconvinced me
[Music]
dead dead
dead dead it does kind of parallel that
moment
he brought up an excellent excellent
point here which is that agnes is a
little further out
yet she can still talk while the others
are still frozen this show sold me on
the fact that
she is uh that no she's probably just
another character and all this stuff has
been like
dismiss direct nods uh for us like
dressing up as a witch having us think
it's i got the hardness perhaps
that point is very very good that she
can actually still talk
and i thought this mo movement was just
like
oh i'm here i'm still here i'm not like
i'm back to reality
you know for that's what i thought it
was but that's true the broach
was missing in the last episode when she
was in the outfit when she was taking
care of the twins
and with quicksilver coming back and
then her searching for the broach would
be very specific
it might be right i feel like i feel
like i've been reconvinced if it's gonna
be showing up now
well and also i mean that does lend
credence to the idea that maybe
mephisto's quicksilver like i don't know
i don't want it to be
in a weird way at least from where i'm
sitting right now but at the same time
that correlation is is
yeah oh that's a really good call do
other people have
alternate names oh it's true monica
geraldine yeah she's still won by agnes
they all do yeah
and if she is not not some human or
which plucked it put into here but some
product
of creating this uh hexagon see
that is a cool concept to me is like who
else you know it's like she was able to
create the children in here who else
might she have created and why
exactly yeah oh damn dude you just
reconvinced me
well it wouldn't be the first time too
that marvel would kind of tweak
the origin or the representation of a
classic character
of course yeah what are you trying to
tell me she came here because
stop it now in that moment herb might
have been about to say
because we're all dead but you know the
id wall does suggest perv is the still
living person
it could be that there was some inciting
incident that did kill these people in
west view before their deaths were
reported
now their souls have been resurrected in
the hecks
some dark implications for the children
now in west view
did wanda resurrect a bunch of dead kids
hallows eve the night dead spirits
i mean that seems like a probability
i ca i could yeah you can see that but
damn that is a little
too bleak to take your character i'd say
what am i i mean
both i'd be down for that i would be i
just have a hard time believing they
would go that far
it would just be such a big thing to
unpack like especially for a disney plus
show
yeah i want especially if there are any
concerns about supernatural i feel like
we have to throw that out but the thing
that
the thing that would also debunk that a
little bit is the fact that monica was
able to go in there and all those other
people as we saw at the end of the last
episodes
you know like like that's a cool theory
but i don't feel like it just
we just soon automatically assume that
they're all dead well and i feel like if
they were
maybe like when vision wakes up norm he
would have died or fallen down or
something instead of
reverting to his own consciousness i
mean you could still chalk that up to
the magic but at the same
time i feel like that would be a tell
monica gets a text from her mystery
engineer friend
now editor john was able to help me
figure this one out take a close look at
that zoom in flip it i think we can make
out a five
word text i'm something hydra
something something something maybe this
engineer has some old hydra tech that
they're going to use
on who this person is check out this
week's episode of rogue theory i think
we covered all the options there so then
darcy tells monica
the energy inside has rewritten your
cells on a molecular level twice
max pad it's changing you yes this
implies wanda's hex
might cause mutations on the dna level
perhaps certain other people in the mcu
were born with genetic predispositions
that when they are hit with this hex
wave cause mutations to get activated
all of what's you how we're getting
these they are yourself clearly being
set up to become photon but her lack of
surprise that her blood work
and her reaction last week to the doctor
suggests to me that monica might have
already been
aware of her mutations so then people
yes yes
true true the ethical considerations of
this scenario as best you could
families and couples stay together most
personalities aren't far off on what's
underneath people got better jobs
you don't think it's wrong we kidding
i'm impressed
yeah pietro knows what these people were
like before the hex
to compare it now and he genuinely wants
to know where wanda got these kids from
maybe because he is mephisto and he had
to use pieces of his soul to construct
he is
awfully cool with it these two are
straight up mystified by one's ability
to raise the dead even if it is inside
west view
you can do that then
so why does wanda see evan peters pietro
as a corpse the way she saw
vision when this pietro was not the one
who died well i think this pietro is
warping wanda's perception to further
convince her that he
is her brother because remember wanda
did not see pietro die
so he might feel like
i'm the one who died i'm your brother
forget how i look and sound a bit
different from who you remember your
brother to be because remember
as pietro said earlier his goal is to
give her
grief because grief enables gaslighting
now hayward's encrypted pile is project
he's got me yeah
oh [ __ ] ugh oh
i don't want it to be oh damn
and you know what though i mean if that
does turn out to be a mephisto in
disguise or something it makes this
whole debate about like
where the x-men coming from like so much
more interesting because you would think
like oh quicksilver he's
here to hail the x-men and maybe he's
actually not but they're still gonna do
it
it's like we thought that the misdirect
nods
might have been about uh alluding to
mephisto
and and agatha harkness right then maybe
the misdirect
is putting peters in here x-men
as the stunt casting and that actually
makes a lot of sense
because yeah i was under the impression
that maybe they had
quicksilver's dead body aaron taylor
johnson's and then they
slammed but why wouldn't he just come
back as aaron taylor johnson
yeah that's the thing that's not why
it's clear to me to confuse her that
this guy is the one yeah
why go with a different person's face
that hasn't been acknowledged or
addressed yet because
that makes sense like okay let me come
here as this dead body let me go into
vision course that way you know that
these are the bullet hole wounds of when
your brother died so that way you
believe it that totally feeds into it
and the fact that he does seem like
ridiculously content and cool with this
whole world
makes a lot of sense too and and then
wanting to get vision out of the
equation
yeah but i just can't get past like why
why evan peters yeah
yeah unless it is just stun casting to
confuse the audience damn but that
i i am convinced that it's it can't just
be evan peters quicksilver brought over
not as cleanly as oh [ __ ] it would have
to be something you got me
you got me no you've changed my mind
damn cataract and this codename could
correspond to vision as a cataract is
when a cloud forms on the
eye that decays one's vision
corpsvision's eyes are clouded
as vision decays though there's a little
way to figure that out
jimmy gadd and james alexander are there
crew members
we saw jimmy gatt in the crowd yeah the
last episode vision disintegrates as the
hex pulls him back in
though the minds
so as long as this hex is operational
and wanda is still alive
the projection of the mind stone
envisions head remains though
vision himself apparently cannot survive
outside this hex and uh yes
visions erosion wait a minute so that's
the
actual mine stone because yeah the
infinity stones were destroyed
and then america returned to the other
ones yeah america did
the whole country yeah that's an
american return the mind stone doesn't
seem to be evaporating at all so
what she created a mind stone or
something or like i guess
just a projection of it is keeping it
cuz because that's not disintegrating
at all no and maybe it's got something
to do with yeah like because she had her
powers awakened through the mind stone
maybe that is like the purest
part of the projected or the reanimated
vision because they share that you know
it's crucial to the both of them or
something
whatever what does it mean in disney
yes visions erosion is kind of like this
shirt this is our custom and unusual
couple of shirts
where is it you can get this at
newrockstarsmerch.com and we are doing a
special sale this weekend for all you
lovers looking to give that special
someone a gift
10 off all new rockstars products what
the hell
why did i buy it a week earlier
[Laughter]
another sign of his meta sentence
because aaron taylor johnson pietro died
before vision
did how would he know that he was dead
but ironically vision
did die twice already once when wanda
blew up the mind stone and then again
when thanos rewound time to rip it out
and that first death that wanna still
feel super guilty over is probably what
trigger wanda's rage
she smashes pietro through these
gravestones one includes the name
janelle samelman who is an a.d for one
division she also works on the fantastic
four
the epitaph real detail it says not
on her side which i think is a huge clue
point in the fact that pietro is not on
wanda's side
at all there's also hell you know pietro
is a kind of virus in west view
anagrams now one that freezes the town i
notice this happens precisely in night
of living dead when the walker is
breaking through the fence precisely
oh i love i i love all that right there
in the graveyard because i
i mean it wasn't until later on after we
were done filming where i realized like
oh [ __ ] she totally knocked him into the
graveyard
when i was like looking for a moment for
the thumbnail and
i'm like that's neat that's clever you
know i wanted him back got her brother
who died but these little i mean i could
totally see how these could be easter
egg clues for sure
yeah not her side virus rested
pieces damn that is so
crap all signs point to a lot of dead
bodies breaking through the fence
precisely as walking dead vision is
breaking through the west
and then
sucks in the sword camp including poor
darcy
i love that christmas story edit there
something that confused the crap out of
me as a kid because i didn't understand
meta pov shifts
something that one division uses
liberally now the sword head
turns into a circus with the agents
becoming clowns and mines
an american horror story freak show
everything he's just playing evan peters
tv
show outside everything becomes an even
earlier form of showbiz and escapism
a big circus tent and i love how one of
these mimes does the invisible wall
because she's now trying to find an
invisible wall of west view herself the
truck turns into a funnel cake truck
full of love another reminder that this
whole hex was based on juana's love for
vision
and the closing shot shows us wanda's
eyes as the scarlet glow fades
you can almost make out the shape of a
person in that red glow especially a
noticeable on the right
again i don't really think wanda is
doing this alone
some other entity is in the shadows
enabling her the true
source of her madness you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
all your wanda vision questions
[Music]
probably not they're probably just
misdirect nods starting off this video
with what you said you s you said you
said
and you shed it and then going i don't
think so
to oh crap i believe him
two that's a damn good court case
argument you presented guys this is why
new rock stars is the best
absolutely subscribe to them as soon as
you can check them out on patreon
get 10 off that shirt now damn it
and um subscribe to us keep a lookout
for one of us
feel so defeated like crap damn it
i thought i knew i thought i had the
theories all worked out
you told me about my heart patron of the
day shout out
pj pandemic jones you know what
one division has been so much fun but
doing these tv shows
on the weekends and stuff makes me a
little bit miss the live streams and you
were one of the people i always remember
meeting you in those and like having
this sort of rolling snowball
you became pandemic jones inside of
those live streams and
i've been missing i've been nostalgic
for those a lot lately so i just want to
shout you out say what's up
wish you well and also thank you for
sending me that driver's license music
video
i got all 45 of your messages about it
and i hope you enjoyed
the reaction because uh i was quite
moved so uh
much love buddy hope you're doing well
you rock buddy happy new year